How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. This is a highly
requested video swing trading using my
fractal model. Now we will talk about
using this on the weekly, the daily, and
the hourly for entries, but it's also
viable to use this for a monthly,
weekly, and then 4hour for entries.
Let's get into the PDF. So, step one is
always going to be getting a weekly
bias. And what do I mean by that? I mean
on the weekly time frame, I want to
anticipate if price is going to move
higher or lower. So, to do that, I will
use liquidity, highs and lows, fair
value gaps, as well as candle closures.
So, here you can see we have internal to
external liquidity with a candle 2
closure. It's reasonable to anticipate
expansion on this candle 3 of the weekly
time frame. So now we have a bias for
the week, right? We want to see this
week trade higher. From here, I'm going
to be looking for a daily swing point to
form the wick of the daily candle. I'll
be looking for a candle 2 or a candle
three on the daily chart. And then I'll
be looking to trade the expansion in the
following candles. So here you can see
if this was Monday, this was Tuesday,
Tuesday is forming a low using a candle
to closure, I can anticipate that
Wednesday and Thursday could expand
higher. Now, Thursday is totally
dependent on Wednesday's closure, but
you get what I mean within the weekly
profile. After I have that daily candle
closure, I'll be making sure that daily
candle has a change in the state of
delivery. So, here you can see on
Tuesday, we have a candle to closure. We
have a change in the state of delivery.
That means it's valid to look for the
fractal model higher in Wednesday. So,
what will I be looking for? I'll be
looking for the wick of candle 3 or
Wednesday to form and then look to get
on side with that. Once I'm on side with
that move, I can hold that through
Wednesday, even Thursday into that drawn
liquidity above. And what are we doing?
We are aligning the weekly time frame
and our bias and anticipation for it to
move higher with a daily swing point and
then an hourly entry. Now, like I said,
this is a fractal concept. So, if you
want to swing trade on the higher time
frames, which I know a lot of people
like to do on crypto, you can use the
monthly time frame, then a weekly swing
point, and then a 4hour entry as well.
So, let's get into Trading View and go
over a few examples. So, here we are in
our first example, and I just want to
see, do I expect the weekly candle to
expand lower or higher? Or it can be as
simple as am I going to reach for
previous week's low or previous week's
high. Well, you can see here we have a
candle to closure on the weekly. So, I
could anticipate price to at least go
towards previous week's low, if not
these lows that are lower. So, with this
weekly bias, I will then go to the daily
chart. Now, do I have a swing point on
the daily to trade away from? No, I do
not. Right. So, I'm not going to be able
to take a trade here because right now I
currently have a candle to closure that
is bullish. Let's see what happens on
this next candle. You can see this
bullish candle 2 closure failed and now
we have a swing point forming to the
downside. And it's nice to see that
these are left because those are failure
swings. So now what do we have? We have
a candle 2 closure that is bearish
aligned with the anticipated weekly
candle to reach for its previous week's
low. But we also have these nice failure
swings down here which could be the full
expansion target. So now that we have a
candle 2 closure, we'll drop down to our
aligned time frame, which is the hourly
chart. So down here on the hourly chart,
you can see we have now formed a
continuation, right? As we have closed
through the series of candles here. Now,
this continuation is not something I
would personally look to trade because
my stop loss is just too big. It doesn't
make sense to put my stop loss all the
way up there. So we have expansion into
some lows. Let's see if we can get on
side before these lows get taken out
here or before these lows get taken out
over here. So, we have nice targets
there as well. We have expansion. Let's
see if we get a new phase of price. All
right, we're already in through that
low. So, let's see if we get a new phase
of price here. All right, I don't know
if this is reversal or retracement
currently. And what is it doing? It is
consolidating. So consolidation, we
sweep out into a fair value on the high.
So this is enough. I could take a candle
to closure entry or I could give it one
more candle to see if it wants to trade
away. It does. I could then take an
entry here. Now you might be saying,
hey, there is no continuation here yet.
And that is valid, right? There is no
continuation yet. There are times where
you can apply your own discretion to the
model to look for entries. Let's see if
we get 2 R, which is just below that
low. And let's see how this works. We
do. And then you can see we get another
potential continuation here. I
personally wouldn't trust this because
it did not reach into here unless we
have SMT on another asset. Let's see if
we get another continuation. Not before
running out this low. But if we're
taking a look at this and rewind, what
do we have? We have an anticipated
bearish weekly candle, right? reach into
its previous week's low as well as these
failure swings below. Then what I'm
going to do is align that with a daily
candle. Here we have a daily candle to
closure and then an hourly entry that
aligns with that. And really what you're
doing is aligning all time frames in one
direction and then trading the trend.
Let's get into another example. Now here
we are in our next example. And if
you've been on my Ninja Trader stream,
you've known I was talking about this
one early into this year. But what do we
have? We have a swing point on the
weekly time frame and we can be looking
to see this trade higher. So if we go to
the weekly chart here, you can see we
have this swing point here and we can
look for it to trade higher here into
all of these failure swings here and
this high. Now what do we notice about
this high here? It just fell shy of that
relevant swing. Now it doesn't really
make sense for me to try to trade a
reversal away from this. So I view this
as a retracement and I want to trade it
back into those equal highs there. So,
with that idea, what would I want to
wait for? Right? And you might see this.
Not this isn't a super clear weekly
candle bias, but I have a clear bias,
which still allows me to look for swing
entries. Now, why wouldn't I want to see
price trade all the way down into this
fair value gap? Well, if during an
expansion, price retraces all the way
down to here, this is when price becomes
bearish, and it might as well just take
out this low. So, I want to see price
remain in the upper half of this, so
ideally in this area before trading
away. But I need to wait for a daily
swing point. Let's see if we can get
that.
Here you can see we do have a daily
swing point. So now what do we have? We
have a swing point aligned with my bias
to these highs, right? And so what I'm
going to do is go down to the hourly
time frame. And I want to look for
protected swings. And what do we notice
here? We have a nice reversal with an
SMT. We'll clear up our drawings here.
And what else do we have? We have price
opening up right near a protected swing.
And I really like the look of this
because we have a nice V-shaped reversal
here. This is what you want to see when
you have a reversal structure
consolidation. Nice V-shaped reversal.
It makes sense to see us retrace back
into the range here as we've taken out
some short-term highs into a gap. So,
what could I do here? Well, really, I
could look to just take an entry
positionally if I wanted to and put my
stop on that protected swing and then
look for the higher time frame
objective, right? Which is that high
right there, which gives us plenty over
our 2R. So, let's see how this works
out. You can see we do get what? If we
missed our first entry right here, we
have a sweep of this low right here. And
then what do we have that nice V-shaped
reversal? You see what we're looking for
here? A nice V-shaped reversal. Nice
V-shaped reversal. And this would have
been another possible entry here is
that's creating a new protected swing.
This would be the intracandle change in
the state of delivery. Does this give 2
R? Yep, there's our 2R. And we could
also look for, you know, around that 4R,
right around our target. Let's see how
this works.
You can see we could have gotten stopped
out right there. And sometimes that
happens, right? Let's see if this other
one still works out.
You can see it takes quite a while, but
that's an example. Not all trades are
going to work out, right? This is a
valid loss, you know, and you could say,
"Oh, I could prevent it, you know, but
at the end of the day, you are going to
take some losses." You can see our first
entry would have worked. We would have
gotten our 3.74R out of it. Second one
would have failed, right? So, that would
be a valid stop-loss to me. It has the
context, it has the bias, and it has the
structure. It just comes and stops us
back out. After we get stopped out, you
know, we do have another V-shaped
reversal, right? and we have another
continuation out of there. You could
still trade that away if you wanted to,
but this is a pretty realistic approach
of what can occur when you're swing
trading. So, let's go over another
example here. What do we have? Well, we
had a bullish candle 2 closure, which
then had an expansion higher, but failed
and formed a bearish candle to closure
to the downside. But on this weekly time
frame, I could anticipate price to want
to move lower. Then I would go down to
the daily time frame because I want to
find a daily swing point that aligns
with that. And what do we have here?
Well, we have a nice V-shaped reversal
or a BPR and a consolidation. So, I want
to see price open, make a high, ideally
running out these swing points right
here before trading lower. So, let's see
if we can get that. Here we do get a
move higher, a nice large wick reversal
candle. We could be looking to trade
that if we wanted to. It's not a candle
2 closure, but it's a reversal and price
should respect the lower half of the
wick if we want to trade that lower
there. Now, we'll see if that provides
an opportunity right. But I also want to
talk about one thing we can do here.
Let's see. Do we get a continuation?
Let's see if we do. We're just going to
be looking for a continuation on the
hourly chart.
And there we get a closure below the
series of upclose candles. So that is a
continuation. I can look to take an
entry there and see if that works out as
we start to trade lower, right? And
we'll look for 2 R. But we can
anticipate expansion,
right? And there we get 2 R. So let's go
back out to the daily time frame. See
how that works out. You can see we get a
nice expansion or strong candle closure
through there. Now we have a
continuation on the daily chart. Now,
since this candle expanded quite a bit,
we could look for entries in this
following candle, but it took out all
these lows here. So, I generally like to
wait for a new phase of price. [snorts]
But here you can see we get a little
consolidation. Let's see if we form a
new swing point.
You can see we do that all in one
candle. Is it possible to trade that
reversal candle? It is. But now we have
a candle to closure going this way. So,
let's see if we can find something on
the lower time frames in here reaching
lower. So going down to the hourly time
frame, what do we have? You can see it's
a bit messy. And this is why I wanted to
talk about this example. You don't have
to use this defined time frame
alignment. If things are a bit messy,
you can move up one time frame. So for
instance, intraday, if I'm on the 30
minute and it's messy, I can move up to
the hourly or in this case, since it's a
bit messy on the hourly, I can always
use the 4hour time frame. And you can
see it cleans it up a bit where we have
a clear consolidation, a V-shaped
reversal. Let's see if we can get a
continuation on the 4hour chart here.
And here you can see we do reach into
this fair value gap here. Let's see if
we can get a continuation or a closure
below here.
And you can see we do. Is that too much
to take an entry? I would probably want
some sort of retracement back into the
range. If I'm going to try to trade to
this low so I can get 2 R. Let's see if
we get that. We do. And then we do get a
move lower. So that is one possibility
that if it is not clean, you can move up
one time frame, right? It doesn't have
to be so defined if you do not want it
to be. But those are two pretty good
examples where you're aligning the
weekly time frame and where you're
expecting it to go and then looking to
trade those daily swing points. You can
trade the reversal candles themselves. I
just prefer to trade that candle three
as I find it easier. Now let's see if we
can keep going here because we are in
this consolidation. We have failure
swings on the highs and we just ran out
this low. If we are going to get a
reaction at this low, what would we do?
Well, let's actually clear up all the
drawings. We have a sweep. This is a
candle to closure closing on its wick.
We'd want to see the upper half
respected. If price is going to trade
higher from this low here, now this
would mean on the weekly time frame.
This is what I like to see. We're either
going to respect 0.5 of this wick and
trade higher or we're going to run out
the low and then we have a larger wick.
So, I'm not expecting as much expansion.
So, how would we want to approach this?
Well, we have the context. We'd want to
go to the hourly and see if we have a
model and then some way to trade this.
So, we'd want to see that area
respected, which is actually just the
T-spot here on the daily and hourly. And
let's see if we get a move, right? And
this might be a bit messy as well,
right? So, we could probably go up to
the 4hour time frame here if we want to,
right? And then we have a pretty clear
4hour fair value gap right in here. We
can see if price reaches back into that
area.
You can see it does. I did skip ahead a
little bit. So, we'll go back to here
where we have a 4hour time frame. And
like I said, you can either just enter
here on the 4hour time frame or what can
you do? You can use what I talked about
in my favorite fractal model video where
I have a 4hour candle. I can go down to
the 15-minute time frame and look for a
fractal model here. Right, we have a
sweep and a closure through confirming
this low and a consolidation. I'd want
to see a sweep of this consolidation if
we're going to trade higher,
right? And you can see in this case, it
just expands without me. But you can see
the context there in ways you can filter
through time frames. You have to find
out what works best for you. Some people
want to stay on the higher time frames.
Some people want more confirmation on
the lower time frames. What I'm trying
to show you here is it really doesn't
matter what time frame you choose as
long as you have the higher time frame
context and understand where price
should trade away from. We know once we
form the low on the 4hour in this fair
value gap here, we don't want to see
price come all the way back down here.
So then we're just looking to find areas
to trade in here into these higher time
frame targets. And before we end this
example, just taking a look at the same
example on the correlated asset or
Ethereum, you can see it's a bit cleaner
here on the 15-minute and we probably
would have been able to find an entry as
we have a protected low here and then
continuations into this area as we trade
higher. I could have taken an entry in
here and had a protected low to trade
away from as we look for two R towards
that higher time frame objective. Let's
get into another example. Now, in this
final example, we will change it up a
little bit. I've been talking about how
you can use the weekly for bias, the
daily for a swing point, and then the
hourly for entries, but you can also
adjust how you approach this. For
instance, you can go directly from the
weekly to the 4hour and just use a
normal fractal model for a swing trade.
You don't need any other alignment
besides that. You just need some
context. And this trade is actually an
example from a trade that I saw a trader
in the lens take. So, you can go ahead
and check that out there on the screen
now. But, let's get into it. What is the
context? We have a expansion lower, a
consolidation, a sweep opposing that
order flow. So what are we looking for
here? Now that we have a candle to
closure, we can be looking for price to
trade lower in this following candle. I
can go directly to the 4hour time frame.
So here we are on the 4hour time frame.
You can see I have the weekly chart up
as well as the daily here. And we are
expanding away, right? We're respecting
the lower half of this wick. And what do
we get next? Right, we have expansion.
And this is looking like a retracement
or a consolidation. So let's see what
happens here. You can see what do we
get? We get a sweep and then we get a
closure through. Right? So that is
creating an opposing candle or a
protected swing and I could look to take
an entry there with my stop there. Now a
lot of you are going to say, "Hey guys,
there's a candle with no wick here." And
yes, if price is so weak that it can't
trade back up into that wick. You can
see it could have done that here. It
doesn't want to. That's fine. and we can
let it trade away once we get a
continuation. I wouldn't want to take an
entry before it does that, but once it
shows me that it's not going to go up
there, I can look for a continuation
lower. And you can see there is 3R. Or
you could be looking for these lows down
here, which is what Daniel did. But
let's see if we can get this right here.
You can see we get a pretty quick move
into that short-term objective. And then
we'll go ahead and watch the rest of
this play out.
And there you can see we hit that final
TP there before we can see if we get a
new phase of price for either a
continuation lower or a reversal. But my
whole point of showing this is there's
lots of ways you can combine the fractal
model in lots of different time frame
alignments you can use. At the end of
the day, you have to figure out what
type of trader you are and what time
frames you prefer. Do you prefer taking
swing trades on the weekly and the
4hour? Do you like to use the weekly,
then the daily, then the hourly? or are
you an intraday trader? You have to
decide that for yourself because no one
else is going to be able to tell you
that. But with that, if you enjoyed this
video, please give it a like and
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
time. Have a good one.